[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bubba watson set to join us
two-time masters champ by the way
link's soul ambassador investor there
bubba joins us can you wear whatever you
want at the masters like you're going to
wear link soul starting thursday
yes i mean i think you can't wear a
t-shirt but you better have pants on
well one thing you better have pants on
and a golf shirt
have you seen anything where you went
wow they allowed him to remember when
david duvall was wearing those like mock
turtlenecks and that was a big deal he
wasn't wearing a golf shirt
i must have been cold there
how did you get involved with link's
soul
uh link soul i've i've known john
ashworth for a long time um
obviously he's a creative mind um
a great man that loves the game of golf
wants to grow the game of golf loves to
give back and so over the years over the
many years that i've known him and and
got to know him even more
the timing was right i wanted a
partnership with a company that that i
could be invested in um that i could uh
have a little bit of influence but also
have you know let let the company
influence me and the charity dollars
they've raised over different t-shirts
and different things
it's exciting to be a part of and i feel
like i'm part of the family but it's so
laid back it's just easy going it's
lifestyle clothing um
and golfing and
surfing any sport that you can think of
that's really what it's about and just
uh
enjoying life so it was an easy fit for
me
when you go to augusta later today
do you have like your routine to prepare
for the first round of the masters does
does that start later today that this is
the normal
progression that you're going to have to
get ready for round one
yes for sure i i show up i get i get to
augusta early i show up and now with the
women's amateur uh with the drive
chipping putt and then me and my wife
play
uh we have a grudge match condoleezza
rice and lee slicedinger uh two members
of augusta so it's boys against girls
and um so we have a grudge match on
sunday afternoon after the drive-through
and putt we go out and play uh past
champions can bring a guest and my wife
is obviously my guest
when did you find out the possibility
that tiger would be playing
gosh i saw
i saw um social media started talking
about tiger being at augusta um
and i guess tiger a week ago somebody
announced that his name was in the field
um i figured he would be at augusta for
the champions dinner no matter what
um but obviously
for the game of golf how exciting i mean
the buzz around the masters is already
high but now having tiger
name on the field list
it's even higher
it's crazy that he could be playing in
this bubba as i've said to my audience
many times just walking that course it's
it's a whole lot hillier than people
think
100 my dad my dad went for his only time
my dad went was in 2008
and um he couldn't walk the course he
didn't know he had rheumatoid arthritis
and he had no idea that um
how hilly it was because on tv you can't
really see it and so he um he sat on one
he watched he watched one tee shot
number nine
number 10 tee shot and 18 because
they're all right there and so that's
what he did waited for me for five hours
for me to hit all those spots
do you remember the first time you
played with tiger
oh first time i played with tiger yes it
was um
if i remember correctly it was a
practice round oh
seven
uh we were at san diego and i knew the
only chance i could play with him is
wake up real early and uh show up and
hopefully he shows up at the same time
and um
i actually got out in front of him and
then he came over uh the north course
and uh in san diego the torrey pines
he came over he was on number nine i was
at number 10 and he um
he came over and said can you can i join
you
and the reason why he and the reason why
he said that is um
is because i sent him a christmas
present in 06.
um dave chappelle
dave chappelle made a skit where they
made fun of tiger and he says uh for
shizzle i've always wanted to say that
and um
so i sent tiger a shirt not knowing him
i sent him a shirt that said for shizzle
um for christmas
and he so that's why when he saw me he
was like oh my gosh so he went over
there and
we became friends ever since you know
he's he's loved me ever since that was
the racial draft on the chappelle show
wasn't it
yeah
and then i mean i know so much about it
because he puts the glove on the wrong
hand puts it like for a left-hander i
mean it's just the red shirt yeah
is augusta set up for a left-hander to
succeed more than a right-hander
i don't know jack nicklaus did pretty
good around there yes he did but he did
well everywhere bubba
he did well
yes for sure
uh tiger has what five yeah jack had six
so us us lefties haven't got to that
level yet but um i think phil has
three
um
i have two like weir so i mean
if you're playing good golf it really
doesn't matter lefty or righty but
obviously history proves that varieties
are doing better yeah but there's more
right-handed golfers bubba so i know but
i didn't want to say that i didn't want
to say that i was just trying to
i was trying to put pressure on all the
righties this year
okay if i gave you one club to play the
masters
let's just play you were going to play
augusta not the masters i gave you one
club and that's all you had
what would you use
always a seven iron always
no matter what the course is it's a
seven iron all day
so if i said you only use a seven iron
what do you think you shoot not augusta
um tournament tees
pretty long
i mean
i would have to say i break 85
um
the green speeds are up to tournament
speeds um yeah it'd be 85 would be would
be really good
what are the benefits aside from being a
former masters champ you get to play
every year you get to go there and play
what are some of the other benefits of
being a masters champ
you get free dinner on tuesday night at
champions dinner okay
okay
um
you know we um
you know being able to show up being
able to take some friends um throughout
the year can you stay on the course
during the masters
um
not during i've never stayed on the
course during the masters
i promise you there's probably some
legends of the game that stayed on site
during the masters
i'm not a legend of the game so i have
not stayed on site
i'd like to know those stories about the
legends of the game who stayed on course
because they probably had to bubba
[Laughter]
but isn't there the uh
isn't there the place where the amateur
stays
yes
yeah so the amateurs stay there um i'm
taking a wild guess jack nicklaus arnold
palmer uh maybe even gary player
probably stayed on site during the
masters um
yeah so you get to play you get to um
have the green jacket in your locker
when you show up
um
you get to bring a guest on sunday the
sunday before my wife's played every
year since i've had that that uh
privilege
you know it really you just belong to
the club even though it's you're not a
regular member it's just they make you
feel so special and part of it that week
and that whole week and that's why i
show up for the ladies amateur and the
uh the drive chip and putt is because i
want to be part of the club i want to
grow the game of golf just like the
membership's trying to do you know i
took a divot one time when i played
there
i brought it home with me
that's bad isn't it
no because there's a lot of people would
love to do that yeah i i still have the
divot no but my wife was like are you
gonna put it in the yard and try to grow
i said i didn't know if i put it under a
grow lamp or something but i
like having people tried to steal the
sand out of augusta or some i don't know
like little little vials that they take
with them or something like i don't want
to get in trouble i don't know if i'll
ever play it again but i took a divot
put it in a baggie
that's sad i should have
i should have taken some of that pine
straw that i hit off of in 2012.
hey uh it's great to have you involved
in length seoul and i know you're uh
involved with a special t-shirt this
week with uh leigh elder there and uh
actually we're showing it right now but
um
no it's great company i'm glad you're
part of it as well and uh you literally
put your money uh where your mouth is
when it came to link soul so it's uh
great to be part of that program with
you bubba thanks for joining us and uh
have fun next week
all right thank you thanks very much for
having me that's bubba watson two-time
masters champ